president told supporters in Nashville
last night that Mexico will eventually
pay for a wall along the border his
comment at a campaign style rally was
rejected by Mexico's president right
away mr. Trump now faces new questions
about his dealings with Attorney General
Jeff sessions over the Russia
investigation major Garrett is at the
White House with more on this story
major good morning good morning the
president's rally drew thousands and
those who were there mostly enthusiastic
but hundreds of seats remained vacant
and as the rally continued some Trump
supporters simply drifted away a sign
that the Trump show with its familiar
but as yet unfulfilled immigration
promises may be less compelling than it
used to be but in the end Mexico's
paying for the law on the road in
Nashville President Trump brought out a
golden campaign oldy and they're going
to enjoy it okay they're going to enjoy
it
Mexican president Enrique Pena Nieto was
watching and tweeted Mexico will never
pay for a wall not now not ever mr.
Trump is having trouble getting the
Republican Congress to fund a wall -
another GOP problem top house
investigator trey Gowdy said the FBI did
not wrongfully infiltrate the Trump
campaigns the FBI did exactly what my
fellow citizens would want them to do
when they got the information they got
and that it has nothing to do with
Donald Trump in Nashville the president
kept his Spygate mantra going so how do
you like the fact they had people
infiltrating our campaign can you
imagine Gowdy said the FBI used an
informant to check on Russian meddling
not at the Trump campaign he was never
the target Russia related to Russia a
special counsel Robert Muller is
investigating the president's dealings
with Attorney General Jeff Sessions
including efforts to persuade sessions
to monitor the original FBI
investigation even after sessions
recused himself from all Russia related
probes the FBI's original
counterintelligence investigation to
Russia was handed off to Muller after
sessions recusal and the president's
decision to fire the FBI director James
Comey now--if Muller's investigators get
a chance in negotiations continue they
want to
question the president about his private
conversations with sessions and his
public criticism of the Attorney General
as they look into possible obstruction
of justice Nora just another big story
not to be missed this morning about
sessions major thank you so much